i know that it's something that you know
you know a large part of america has
felt um and i think it's just
unfortunate i think things like uh you
know organizations like the nba or
anything that's in the entertainment um
phrase it only benefits them to be
um to be in the middle ground um but i
think because of
because of you know maybe one group or
one side being able to to to frame the
argument um and make it a moral you know
argument on a lot of the things that are
happening take the vaccine and take blm
to where if you disagree you're an evil
person
did the team know what you were going to
do on that day when you decided to stand
and everybody else kneeled
so there's a lot of details in the book
that i explained like i called the um i
called somebody that was in the magic
organization the night before because i
didn't want to catch them off guard so i
called them and we we had a whole team
meeting that
the day before so we had a team meeting
and the the executives of the team you
know came in and said you know what we
support you guys on whatever you decide
to do a team had already knelt earlier
that day and so they were like you were
going to give you guys time to just talk
about it as a team so they locked they
walked out and the guys are just like yo
we don't have a choice this is what we
have to do we have to kneel we can't be
the only team that doesn't and then one
of my teammates look at me and they say
yo jonathan what are you going to do
like that kind of they kind of knew i
don't know why he's like what are you
going to do i said fellas i'm not gonna
wear that t-shirt and i'm not gonna deal
with the national anthem um and then i i
called you know somebody in the magic
organization that night and kind of let
them know and they just said okay you
know we'll handle it tomorrow
were you uh
in retrospect i mean were you thinking
man like this could cause all kinds of
problems you know i mean look what's
going on with enis cantor right now the
guy's in the prime of his career he
can't get a contract i mean that that it
just creates headaches that even if you
have all the skills and everything else
the teams are just like i don't want to
deal with the headache everyone else is
going along and and that's the type of
people we want with us
look the the night before i stood um i
was on the phone with my pastor and i
was letting him know i was like yo i
don't think you understand how big this
is gonna be like you know people are
getting cancelled i i didn't sign my
contract yet um i didn't sign my
contract extension so they would and the
possibility of me getting canceled then
i wouldn't have the contract that i have
right now um but yeah
i knew the backlash that was going to
come i knew you know the [ __ ] and the
uncle tom i know the you know the people
who would automatically take it in and
make it about the flag and the national
anthem and all that stuff i knew all
that stuff was going to come but at the
same time you know the one thing that my
pastor said to me is you cannot stand
for god and god not stand for you and so
i knew what i was standing for i wasn't
standing for a movement i wasn't
standing for a side i was standing to
offer that message that we all fall
short of god's glory every single one of
us and
with anyone to throw stones you're
throwing stones from a glass house and
so um what i tried my best to do is just
kind of you know come from a humble
position and say man if if we could love
each other the way that god loves us
which is in spite of our sin in spite of
our faults then we could really change
the world
what about some of your uh your
teammates it sounds like maybe some of
them
kind of wanted to do the same but felt
the pressure and just couldn't couldn't
bear it
well
at the time i i didn't know that um and
i wouldn't even say my teammates per se
but i had conversations with other guys
um you know around the league and even
in other sports so after i had left the
bubble i hurt myself the next game i
tore my acl the next game and uh i got a
call from a soccer player here in
orlando and he was like hey you know i
saw what you did i want to do the same
thing but i'm terrified and this is this
is a white guy so he's he's extra
terrified
[Laughter]
and so you know i was able to talk to
you know talk him through it and and
encourage him to stand up for what he
believes in um but you know it was a
very emotional moment and so i was
expecting you know guys on my team to
disagree with me i was even expecting it
to get heated and so um you know details
in the book there's a there's a team
meeting that happens the day after i
stood and it it's it's a heated
conversation between me and the guys and
uh but it pretty much ends with look you
guys know for what you believed in and i
stood for what i believed and it wasn't
a protest for you guys as protests it
was just because i see the same things
that you guys see but i don't believe
that you know the black lives matter
organization or kneeling for the
national anthem i'm wearing a t-shirt is
the answer
do you uh
what's your take on just sort of how
generally sports has become so
politicized i mentioned to you when i
saw you in orlando that as a big i grew
up the biggest nba fan you can ever
imagine i mean basketball i love
basketball as much as you love
basketball but i don't really watch
anymore i just don't watch because it
became so politicized
every time i turn on an nba game all
they're doing is talking about
basketball uh talking about i wish they
were talking about basketball they're
talking about politics or they got the
blm logo out or they're analyzing some
race event and i'm just like man i can't
take it anymore um do are the players
talking about that too is there some
level of frustration that you guys
aren't just focused on basketball
no i i haven't had that conversation
with any players um and i i know that
it's something that you know you know a
large part of america has felt um and i
think it's just unfortunate i think
things like uh you know organizations
like the nba or anything that's in the
entertainment um
phrase it only benefits them to be um to
be in the middle ground um but i think
because of
because of you know maybe one group or
one side being able to to to frame the
argument um and make it a moral
you know argument on a lot of things
that are happening take the vaccine and
take blm to where if you disagree you're
an evil person and so it's easy for them
to kind of take that moral high ground
and say this is the only way this is the
right way to handle something
but um
again i think it would be in the best
interest of the nba or any organization
that just say you know this this we
should be in the middle and we should
allow people to you know to watch us and
enjoy and if an individual player wants
to use their platform to speak on
something i think that they should have
the absolute right to like like i'm
doing right now so
if anybody in league wants to stand up
and say that that was wrong or used an
individual platform that's great but i
think that i think the nba um should try
their best to kind of you know be in the
middle
i agree so all right so you so you stand
for the national anthem then you give
this incredible talk at the at the post
game on media day
about the vax uh you get some strange
media reaction were you kind of
surprised where you were welcomed and
where you were kind of shunned after
that
no i wouldn't say that i was surprised
um i definitely you know because you
know it was it was during the national
anthem so there's the there's a side of
the owl that that is going to embrace
that and even you know the overwhelming
support of christians and everybody that
that agree with me on that front so i
don't i wasn't surprised at all about
the calls that i got and the different
you know media personalities that wanted
to talk to me afterwards um i would say
the only thing that i maybe was
surprised of was that maybe nobody on
the other side wanted to even have a
conversation and so uh
and and i i i think just in the way that
i kind of phrased my argument or the way
i went about it i would have more people
to say you know what well let's just
talk about it you know i wasn't somebody
that was saying you know you guys are
wrong and this is terrible and i i
didn't come from that standpoint and so
i would have definitely been open to
having more conversations with the other
side but you know i went where i was
welcome and i just tried my best to
continue to to push that christ first
message um and go from there
so let's talk about the the faith part
of this because obviously you've
mentioned your faith a few times it's
it's
clearly a key part of your life uh were
you always a believer did your family uh
come from a deep religious background so
i i wasn't
i wasn't always a believer but we grew
up in church when we were young like
like
all the time we were always in church um
but then i moved from bronx new york to
naples florida and my parents split up
and uh my dad was like my hero but he
was really like the spiritual foundation
of our family um and so i went from a
predominantly black
neighborhood to a predominantly white
neighborhood and i really really
struggled with fitting in and so i tell
in the book a couple of early instances
about just how terrible that was at
getting the other kids to like me and
early on i developed the nickname
ethiopia uh because i was so skinny and
obviously dark skinned and so um i it
was the first time that i became really
self-conscious like in new york
everybody was the same it was it was fun
but once i got to naples i was like
i always tried so hard to fit in and to
kind of
work for the love of my peers that i
started to develop anxiety i started to
develop fear um and then i found
basketball and i was able to kind of put
everything in the basketball and that
brought me the people the girls that
wanted to be around me the guys i wanted
to be around me i started to make those
friends and those peers but i still
struggle with those things in the
background and so i get to florida state
i'm the number one player in the state
of florida everybody's expecting me to
be this great player that takes them to
the championship but i'm still
struggling with these things behind the
scenes and so i had anxiety attacks
while i'm on campus and i passed out in
class and all these different things and
everybody's like what what is going on
with you um and and so but for me and
and it really is a wild story in the
book i get to the nba i'm living my life
i'm doing my thing and then i get
injured
and i get i'm on my i'm at my apartment
and i get on the elevator and a guy
stops me and he says i can tell you how
to be great and i said tell me how to be
great i'm jonathan isaac what do you
mean
he's like uh you got to know jesus and
i'm like jesus man like you know i grew
up christian all this stuff yeah yeah
yeah
but from that point on like my life
really does
get flipped upside down if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell